um we want to go somewhere where
something's happening so we we're
looking for shows about
some stories that are big
you know marquee stories you've heard of
the ark of the covenant and the oh my
god speaking of
why do you have it is it there at your
house the ark of the covenant no it's in
um where do they think it is right now
ethiopia ethiopia they think it's in
utopia it's under jerusalem it's in
someone's garage and because you're
watching all that stuff from like like
graham hancock stuff and yeah i you know
i i it's it's a shadowy trail the ark of
the covenant it sort of vanishes off the
map a long long time ago and
who knows where it is what do you what
do you think it is i mean
base level i think there was a box that
was venerated that was kept in the
temple of solomon that was
believed by the hebrews to be the box
that contained
the
broken tablets of the ten commandments
and what else is in there the broken
staff of aaron is in there and some mana
and i you know like whether or not
that's what was in there you know there
are lots of objects that are venerated
that they're like that's that's what
that thing is so yes for sure there was
a a chest that was in that temple um and
that temple was destroyed and jerusalem
was sacked and was then resacked and you
know i mean over the history of
jerusalem is like
you know um
the babylonians are here and then the
the arabs are here and the christians
are here and then the arabs are here
again and you know i mean it's like it
goes back and forth and back and forth
and so um
you know where does it go in all of that
i don't know it's a pretty shadowy trail
um there are these whisperings oh maybe
it went here maybe it went back to
babylon maybe it maybe it was hidden
underneath the city of jerusalem there's
a whole tradition that says oh it went
to ethiopia
um you know i'm sure that it was
considering it was it was believed to be
this incredibly holy thing
unless it just ended up under a pile of
rubble you know like in a in a
building collapse or something it
probably was squirreled away off
somewhere
to me that the challenge with the ark is
like there just isn't enough of a paper
trail it's like you just don't i mean it
could be anywhere
yeah and if it was i mean we we have
descriptions from the bible of what it
what it looked like but you know if it
was wooden if it was made of some
organic material and i mean who knows
you know i mean it might be i mean i've
been very curious about it isn't there a
lot of
um
theories on the fact that the ark kind
of fits perfectly into let's say the the
what would be maybe a sarcophagus they'd
call it in the king's chamber in the
great pyramid it actually like the
dimensions fit correctly inside of that
and that like isn't there some some sort
of mystery around like a blue mist
energy
where the ark has been
um
i mean there and then why does everyone
why did people get sick around it too
because there's stories and old stories
about people not wanting to be around
the ark because it would it was
killing people well power god type stuff
i mean this is the kind of like you know
this is this is the
the thing about the ark and it's the
thing about
you know there there are a number of
things like the arc that people just
kind of
um graft onto
and and the the great pyramid is is like
this as well these objects or these
constructions that are
so mystical to people that
that that kind of
your head spins and people concoct a lot
of theories about what they are and how
they were built and what they were used
for you know it's it's like it's tough i
mean the ark is
at its core
it's a symbol
of god it's a symbol of
god you know his his commandments his
power um his presence and and bringing
that presence into the holy land so it's
like it is this incredibly important
symbol
for
uh both the jewish and christian faiths
and
at the same time it may be you know it
probably was a real object and so
i think when you have this intersection
between a physical thing and something
that is mystical
then suddenly we concoct a lot of ideas
about it i mean i personally
see the ark as something that probably
did exist and probably is gone forever
you know i mean i think it is a it is
there's just no
could somebody open some chamber
underneath jerusalem one day under the
walls of jerusalem and fi i mean it's
not impossible
um it certainly is a very particular
looking object the way that that it's
described with these angel wings and
these you know um
on top but i but i if i was a betting
man i would say the ark is vanished into
the pages what the hell are you going on
an expedition for
that's a good question
um that's a great question but you know
this is this is kind of what the show's
about it's like it's kind of about this
exact conversation which is like
we all know the ark most of us know it
from you know um temple or sunday school
or indiana jones
what's the deal with the ark right i
mean that's that's that is kind of also
at the core of of our show is this
exploration of what's the real deal with
object x or with mystery y right so
we'll go looking for for things where
there's a story that you know or you
think you know and then we get into well
what's what's real or what can we really
say you know we're doing a show right
now on moses speaking of the ark um
we're doing a show on uh mysteries of
moses and the ark is part of that but
but only sort of tangentially really but
there's this other big thing which is
like
was moses a real person like is there a
historical moses like was there a guy
who genuinely was raised
with the pharaoh in egypt right figured
out he was hebrew uh or or that he was a
semite figured out that that he was not
an egyptian saw the these egyptian
slaves being mistreated and said let my
people go we're getting out of here
we're going to the holy land like did
any of that really historically happen
right so that's a huge difficult
question and so it's really fun to go
and meet with really smart people who
are archaeologists and egyptologists and
historians who can shed light on on
those questions because
you know we think about these these
characters uh and and we don't often
think like okay if there was a moses
like where's he buried and there are
there are multiple places that claim to
be the tomb of moses
in the world and i mean [ __ ] we don't
even know where jesus is really buried
well there we go so another question is
he could be in another big huge you know
difficult question is like i mean
there's a theory he might be in india
right like there's
yeah the other day somebody emailed me
this whole thing about the life of jesus
in india you know so exactly
these are the fascinating things that we
dig into are these questions of like
looking at these stories and figuring
out not just fact from fiction but but
like
what does the archaeological record show
what does history show um and it's tough
because
look i mean whenever you deal with
especially things like the ark or moses
or jesus
you're treading into an area of faith
too so so yeah it's also this question
of like you have to be really cautious
and diplomatic about how you approach
those things yeah well what about
something really important to a lot of
people what about the burning bush do
you think that he was just high
um
you know
there's theories on that too this is a
weird thing like in in the story of
moses
there's a lot of really wild
supernatural stuff happening like there
are these bushes that are burning that
are talking there are staffs that are
turning i don't know have you ever been
high before sometimes a bush might talk
to you right there are these plagues
these i mean
this whole situation in in the story of
moses where moses says to the pharaoh
look let my people go or god is really
gonna you know whoop you and pharaoh's
like yeah no i don't think so and god
unleashes these horrendous plagues on
egypt that are you know like rivers
turning to blood and boils and lice
yeah i mean all sorts of horrible stuff
and then the last of these plagues that
the tenth plague is like the nastiest of
all which is that god is gonna kill
every firstborn egyptian son he's gonna
kill all these babies right so like this
is like really like the story of moses
is
is is kind i mean i again i don't mean
to be disrespectful to it religiously
but just narratively it's like an action
movie like it is like a hollywood
blockbuster which is why it was a
hollywood blockbuster because it is like
this incredible story of supernatural
good versus evil and you know you've got
these villains and the pharaoh and and
this reluctant hero and moses like the
whole thing is just like a movie it's
this great story so i'm really excited
to dig into it on the show because
it is one of those things where like we
all know this character everyone knows
moses everyone knows that name
who is he who was he was he you know did
he exist so that's that's the show in a
nutshell
[Music]